glauben sie an magie
nein aber sie haben doch bestimmt schon
mal für einen freund die daumen gedrückt
damit alles gut kommt auf holz geklopft
oder einen glücksbringer zur prüfung
mitgenommen
warum tun die aufgeklärten menschen
solche dinge und hilft es uns wirklich
dabei glücklich zu werden
große fragen aber mein heutiger gast
weiß rat
eckart von hirschhausen ist mediziner
kabarettist und moderator und ein
experte wenn es um wunder geht
herzlich willkommen herr von
hirschhausen dank für die einladung ja
glauben sie denn an wunder
ja also wunder ist erstmal das worüber
wir uns wundern und ich möchte mich dass
ich in einer sendung über philosophie
eingeladen wurde
was ich aber sehr freut und ich glaube
sogar angst das hat das gesagt staunt
ist der anfang aller philosophie und ich
habe mich als kind schon über
medizinische dinge im körper gewundert
woher weiß die kopfschmerztablette wo
der kopf ist wenn man die schlug die
zuerst mal die völlig falsche richtung
von zäpfchen ganz abgesehen
also ich finde wir wundern uns
eigentlich viel zu wenig über das
wunderwerk was wir sind in körper und
geist
das heißt nicht dinge die
außerordentlich sind solange ich das
auch täglich danach wundervoll sein
dingen die wir nicht verstehen ja also
jesus konnte wasser in wein verwandeln
aber jeder zuschauer ist in der lage
über nacht aus dem ganzen rhein wieder
wasser zu machen ich finde dass
mindestens genauso erstaunt nicht wir
haben im vorfeld der sendung eine kleine
straßenumfrage gemacht und haben die
leute genau das gefragt glauben sie an
wunder und wir schauen uns das große so
spannt das gerechte wurde ich für mich
absolut natur
ja ich finde das allumfassende sich
heißt der größten wunder ist für mexiko
wo man irische tochter tisch hauen und
das ist so einfach nur schade dass du
als baby haarwachstum und einfach gesund
teil kommt ich war zum islam im alltag
beeinflusst
der beschissenen stieg sie und es wird
also das ist für mich alles und das ganz
ohne super guten tag vor meinem vater
der kollege hatte ein freund und der
stammtisch ist zum beispiel das bild
soll es zeichne sich nehmen da sollen
anderen übernatürlichen der glaube ich
nicht und warum glauben christen ja da
habe ich eine vorstellung dass komplexe
zusammenhänge halt einfach erklärt
werden früher eigentlich das gebiet wo
man sich nach lehre dann schnell
zurückgeführt wurden das verursacht hat
und dass man so die wunders ich
konstruiere ja völlig unterschiedliche
antworten der eine glas nicht daran er
ein skeptiker dann jemand sagt ein kind
ist ein wunder hat die natur vielleicht
oder dann dieses beispiel ein bild eines
verstorbenen das dann zu boden fährt
piquet war bis dahin aber das passt das
beispiel was ist gleich ein wunder
es gibt einen einen tollen
neuropsychologen hier in der schweiz
peter brugger hat der viel darüber
geforscht hat wie aberglaube sozusagen
oder magisches denken ist der bessere
ausdruck dafür im kopf entsteht und den
habe ich auch in meinem buch wunder
wirken wunder intensiv zitiert und
befragt der war sehr hilfreich weil wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass sozusagen
unser gehirn designt ist um überall
verbindungen zu sehen und unterstellt
ständig kausale beziehung also ursache
wirkung dass dieses foto vom tisch fällt
wird in unserem hirn verkoppelt mit
einem anderen eindruck nämlich dass
heute ein besonderer tag ist von dem
todesfall
nun muss man sich als skeptiker
natürlich fragen wie oft ist dieses bild
schon vorher runtergefallen und wir
haben aufgehoben und hingestellt und
haben uns das nicht gemerkt weil es eben
nicht merkwürdig war unser gehirn gibt
dingen eine bedeutung und wir müssen
eben aufpassen dafür ist die philosophie
sozusagen als denkschulen natürlich sehr
geeignet oder auch der skeptische
wissenschaftliche denken wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht unseren eigenen
kontrolle illusion oder ursache wirkungs
beziehung auf sitzen denn gerade wenn
wir an
tagen gerne gerade wenn wir verliebt
sind zum beispiel ist die ganze welt
verzaubert über als sehen wir zeichen
hier fällt ein rotes auto vorbei mein
schatz wird auch ein rotes auto das
beweist er denkt gerade ja das ist unter
verliebten normal in der psychiatrie
kann man dafür eine diagnose bekommen ja
das ist wahrhaft das erleben also wir
sind sozusagen von der grundausstattung
her sagen dafür gemacht wenn das gebüsch
wackelt dahinter erst mal ein
gefährliches tier zu vermuten weil es in
der evolution sinnvoller war einmal
zuviel abzuhauen als einmal zu wenig und
wenn es nur der wind war dann hat sich
das in luft aufgelöst und dafür brauchen
wir eben den humor mein anderes
lieblingsthema dass wir dann über unsere
eigenen trugschlüsse auch lachen können
also das ganze hat eine evolutionäre
ursache dass ich eine überaus diese
muster erkennen und zusammenhänge sehen
wo vielleicht acht grad kann es jeder
von den zuschauerinnen zuschauern kennt
dieses beispiel man denkt an jemanden
und er ruft an oder sind noch da und ich
meine dass ich wahrscheinlich sagen ja
aber dann musste müssen sie sich
natürlich fragen
ich gehe in die badewanne denkt kaum
jemand dann ruft er an und das ist
natürlich die beste geschichte die man
weitererzählen
wie oft denkt sagen jemand der ruf nicht
an würdest du das weitererzählen nein
das interessiert auch keine so dass wir
sind hungrig nach wundergeschichten und
man muss dann wenn man wissen will wie
sind die tatsächliche ursache
wirkungsbeziehungen ein bisschen
wissenschaftlich herangehen das heißt
ich frage mich wie oft ruft jemand an an
denen ich überhaupt nicht gedacht habe
wie viele haben eine nummer und wie oft
bade ich überhaupt ja dann kann man sich
das ein bisschen zurecht legen und in
meinem buch wunder wirkt wunder habe ich
mich ja vor allem damit beschäftigt wie
dieser wunder glaube unglaubliche
auswirkungen auf die medizinische
versorgung hat weil die die schulmedizin
die akademische medizin diese
psychologie der heilung über die letzten
50 jahre komplett ignoriert hat und
sagen gering geschätzt hat immer gesagt
ja ja das ist doch nur placebo effekt
wir haben das sagen schlecht geredet den
leuten ausgetrieben und die menschen
sind dann abgewandert sind hinzu
alternativ medizin zu
komplementärmedizin wo es ja ein riesen
schillerndes spektrum gibt von
sinnvoller naturheilkunde die auch in
der schweiz zu
in deutschland sehr stark ist und auch
wissenschaftlich prüfbare
pflanzenheilkunde zum beispiel ist alles
sind wohl ein bisschen eben zu total
esoterischen unsinn und manchmal
wirklich lebensgefährlicher krebsmedizin
gesicht so nennt und in wirklichkeit
nichts gegen krebs ausgerichtet darüber
werden wir gleich noch sprechen mich
interessiert ist noch ich glaube nicht
alle menschen sind gleich wunder gläubig
oder dieses magische denken ist bei
einigen stärker ausgeprägt der stelle
schreiben im buch auf das hat kann sein
dass bestimmte leute egozentrischer sind
oder so eine persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
neurotizismus symbiotisch ausgeprägt
haben dass sie aus absicht beziehen eher
zufälle
also das hat ganz grob damit zu tun ob
wir männer sind oder frauen frauen sind
tendenziell leichter sagen ein magisches
denken heranzuführen lesen er russ coop
sehen er sozusagen auch gesprächsbedarf
über diese dinge männer sind tendenziell
erst sein rationales machen woran das
liegt frauen sind per se empathische und
sagen er sagt auch interessiert dinge zu
vermuten die die da sein können aber
nicht sagen müssen kinder sind natürlich
sehr viel magischem denken ich schreibe
auch wie meine patentochter zum beispiel
durch das thema tanz und stößt gegen den
tisch und dann haue ich auf den tisch
und sagt wilder tisch macht das nicht
normal und das tanzt sie halt weiter und
ein erwachsener haut gegen tisch sagt
auch heute ist nicht mein tag setzt sich
aufs sofa guckt fernsehballett und
verfettet und stirbt da denke ich daran
kann man gut erklären dass dieses
magische denken ja eine sehr sinnvolle
positive psychologische wirkung hat
nämlich es gibt uns in bereichen wo wir
manchmal eben auch verzweifeln könnten
über unsere machtlosigkeit das gefühl
ich habe einfluss auf mein leben ich bin
selbst wirksam und da haut man auf den
tisch und sie es mit sich wieder im
rhein statt sich in selbst vorwürfen
nach
ja ich sollte gar nicht tanzen zu
zerfleischen und das magische denken ist
deswegen in drei großen bereichen so
wichtig nämlich bei gesundheit und
krankheit beim wetter da gibt es auch
unglaublich viele rituale wie man das
wetter früher versucht hat sie
beeinflusst wir amüsieren uns wenn in
afrika getrommelt wird damit gerechnet
hat und dann sagt man in deutschland zum
beispiel heute könnte es wegen ich nehme
ein schirm mit denn wenn ich ein schirm
da war habe regens nicht ja als wenn die
wolke in die tasche gucken kann und den
schirm entdeckt dann sich entscheidet
weiter zu pflegen also wenn man anfängt
über das magische denken nachzudenken
muss man oft schmunzeln beim würfeln hat
doch jeder irgendwie ein einmal ein real
was dann wo ich brauche eine hohe zahl
der muss sich hohe energie in den
würfelbecher stecken bis der würfel gar
nicht mehr weiß was ich von ihm will er
nach im alltag gibt so viele sagten eben
das daumendrücken ist auch schon so
etwas oder glücksbringer zum beispiel
eine kette nimmt man mit und
faszinierend waren sich in der
vorbereitung auf die sendung in sport
also sportler haben unglaublich viele
rituale bis irgendwie hin zu fast
irgendwas nicht zwanghaften handlungen
bei rafael nadal haut zb und wir haben
ein paar sehr schöne beispiele
zusammengestellt und schauen wir uns
kurz zusammen an angst einflößende
rituale geisterbeschwörung und voodoo
nicht nur bei den neuseeländischen rugby
frauen sind alle mittel recht und zum
sieg zu kommen
[Musik]
tennis-cracks rafael nadal nutzt beim
aufschlag ganz spezifische abläufe um
ein us schlagen zu können
[Musik]
auch in afrika haben wurde und hexerei
ihren festen platz und versprechen hilfe
auf dem spielfeld ein junger fußballer
erhält durch einen voodoo priester
beistand
das blut des frisch geschöpften hans
soll die beine des spielers immun gegen
verletzungen machen
[Musik]
anschließend schreibt der voodoo
priester die namen der gegner auf eier
und schmettert sie zu boden
so soll der gegner geschwächt und
verflucht werden
in japan soll es glück bringen ein
silvester einen winterlauf in eisiger
kälte zu machen
das ritual beim rugby ist
augenscheinlich geschlechtsunabhängig
[Applaus]
sutter weist diese ja was zum teufel ist
damit den menschen los warum macht man
das also eine ganze sendung ist toll wie
sie es zusammen geschnitten haben
also dieser beschwörung zauber der der
steckt ja auch in der medizin sowie so
drin also auf eine art und weise
versuche ich ja auch in meinem buch
näher zu bringen wir sind eigentlich als
ärzte auch in der tradition von den
medizinmännern der da das bein
geschmiert damit nichts passiert und wir
haben auch eben keine hühner köpfe mehr
um den hals aber wir haben ein
stethoskop und man trägt es so als
zeichen und sofort mit weiß entschied
wer bin ich bin ich jemand anders und
was mein anliegen ist ist ja dass die
ärzte verstehen wenn menschen so sind
wie sie sind und gerade wenn sie krank
sind haben sie angst haben sie ein
bedürfnis nach ritual nach einer
erklärung auf von schuldfragen also ich
schreibe auch relativ viel ernste sachen
in dem buch nämlich zum beispiel die
frage was das für dich selber tun
nämlich krebs hätte ich schreibe von
ihrem freund von mir der schwere krebs
erkrankt ist und wie der auch natürlich
alle register zieht von bestrahlung oder
operation ein bisschen zu einem heilungs
gottesdienst wo ich ihn begleitet habe
und wo ich sagt wenn ich alles was was
eben sagen das gefühl gibt ich kann
selber was beitragen zu meiner heilung
ist doch gut und nach immerhin ist eine
illusion ist ja also eine illusion ist
das finde ich ein
doppel will dich begriff weil für ihn
ist es ja dann auch teil seiner realität
und wer bin ich umgeben das auszureden
also wenn man sagt dass das positive
erwartungen im körper manifeste
neurobiologische chemische prozesse
startet sowie stress und runter zieht
kann eben eine positive erwartung die
selbstheilung unglaublich stützen und
gefährlich wird es nur wenn andere ist
illusion ausnutzen wenn ich behaupte
hier wenn du dieses pärchen nimmst dann
gehen alle deine leiden weg und das ist
ein riesenmarkt deswegen bin ich auch
sehr klar sagen den bullshit von dem
sinnvollen einsatz von psychologischer
medizin zu trennen also wenn ich ihnen
corinne pulver verkauf oder vitamin b 17
war so gar nicht gibt aber wo dann
neuzusagen aprikosen kern hilfen gegen
krebs sie sollen bitte endlich beweise
liefert nur die klappe halten denn die
spielen mit menschenleben daran wird es
für mich ganz klar gefährlich aber bis
dahin wenn man sagt dass die ärzte viel
mehr darüber wissen müssten die ihre
worte 30 40 prozent der wirkung des
medikamentes sind dann ist meine
forderung ganz klar die
medizinstudierenden sollten genauso
viele stunden wie sie über bio chemie
und pharmakologie lernen sollten sie
über kommunikation psychologie und ihre
persönlichkeitsbildung lernen damit sie
wissen ich bin selber teil der
behandlung und das findet eben in
unserem akademischen system ist heute
praktisch nicht statt
ich möchte mit ihnen gleich später noch
über den placebo effekt sprechen ist er
selbst ein wunder ist unerklärlich wie
das geht das positive erwartungen nach
positive folgen haben
zunächst interessiert mich noch diese
dieser arbeite habe im auto
ich meine es gibt beispiele ich würde
mich eher als skeptiker bezeichnen aber
wenn man sagt ein pullover von adolf
hitler zum beispiel angenommen denn gsw
wäre gewaschen und ich wurde gefragt
würde ich den anziehen
ich sage nein würde ich nicht anziehen
aber ich mich frage warum habe ich keine
erklärung ja wird wo steckt das böse
steckt das zwischen den maschen ist das
nicht durch das 90 grad programm also
das ist ein gutes beispiel das ist ein
beispiel für etwas was die psychologen
konnten also ansteckung
dahinter steckt auch wieder eigentlich
eine wichtige beobachtung der menschen
früher gab's absurde krankheits
vorstellungen warum heißt malaria
malaria malaria wir hatten die idee dass
es aus der schlechten luft kommt dass
die mücke in der luft der überträger ist
das war den menschen nicht bewusst
aber trotzdem hatten sie assoziiert
irgendwas hat es irgendwas überträgt
sich da und weil man eben nicht genau
wusste wo das übertragbare steckt hat
man dann gegenstände von menschen die
sozusagen als böse als infektiös galten
auch mieten also dahinter steckt
eigentlich evolutionär psychologisch
auch was sinnvolles und das wäre jetzt
eigentlich überall ausgenutzt in der
ganzen werbung als ja das ist jeder
gegenstand symbolisch aufgeladen und
verspricht mir ein glückliches leben
eine neue person zu sein die ganzen
marken psychologie ist ist klar cdu
medizin wenn man so will weil man das
gefühl vermittelt im kapitalismus wenn
ich produkte kaufe die aufgeladen sind
magisch durch einen berühmten menschen
oder durch eine marke die ich wieder
erkenne bin ich teil von etwas größerem
das ist quasi religiöse über das gefühl
haben ich werde dazu gehören wenn ich
die richtigen ton schuhkauf dass es
total krank und deswegen glaube ich eben
hilft es darüber aufzuklären darüber zu
lachen und zu fragen in welchen
bereichen ist es vorteilhaft für
menschen das bewusste einzusetzen
ein beispiel aus dem osten eine
beschäftigung mit dem glück leute an gar
nicht wie viel einfluss ihrer täglichen
routinen und ihr unbewusstes schneider
über dinge die ärgerlich sind schief
gelaufen sind
die sozusagen unglück bedeutet wie sich
das verfestigt dadurch dass man ständig
immer dinge redet an dem man etwa nichts
mehr ändern kann oder die nie eintreffen
oder die dieser tage nicht
lösungsorientiert sind und ein einfaches
gegen ritual ist zum beispiel am abend
ein glücks tagebuch zu schreiben gezielt
sich zu fragen wofür bin ich heute
dankbar
was war heute schön und dann trainiert
man sein gehirn um nämlich dinge anders
wahrzunehmen und wertzuschätzen die da
sind stadt immer sozusagen in diese
leere hinein zu projizieren machen sie
das ja ich habe das nur zeit lang
gemacht und es ist verblüffend wie man
das wirklich üben kann morgens beim
aufstehen zum beispiel auch ein
einfaches ritual sich zu überlegen wofür
stehe ich halt auf die meisten menschen
beginnen den tag mit negativen gefühlen
die das erste was man denken welcher
vollidiot tat ist ein weg aus dieser
zeit gestellt und das macht den
unterschied ob ich sagen jetzt mit mit
so einer haltung von ich bin dagegen
aufstehen oder mit einer haltung ich bin
dafür sehr großer fan von jens corssen
wunderbarer trainer und coach auch
inzwischen ein freund und vernehmen
kommt diese bekannten übung und ich sage
mal beim aufstehen überlegen wofür stehe
ich heute auf und mein zusatz ist wenn
nichts einfällt liegen
[Musik]
ich meine die wichtigkeit von ritualen
vielleicht sollten wir auch noch kurz
darüber sprechen der deutsche philosoph
hans georg gadamer geschrieben man muss
rituale betreiben damit man lernt über
wichtige dinge nachzudenken wie zum
beispiel den tod oder die geburt oft
haben ihre tägliche rituale wenn man die
sprache versagt eine sehr emotionale
situation sind ist es auch ein mikro
sozusagen da ein ritual zu machen und
sagen halt gibt wenn man sich nicht
verloren ist ich habe den gerade mal
noch erlebte ich habe den heidelberg
medizin studiert und
hab ich glaube ich auch schon um die 90
und ist für mich so wirklich eine der
berührendsten erfahrungen meiner
studienzeit wie eine ein mensch der
schon ziemlich gebrechlich ist im geiste
so hell wach und klar sein kann und dann
ohne manuskript einfach unter zwei
stunden die philosophie näher gebracht
hat und die rituale die gala beschreibt
die sind ganz wichtig weil sie und
struktur geben unser wir sind durch
human beings storytelling anthologie
sind bedürftig nach geschichten wir sind
ständig dabei uns selber auch eine
geschichte darüber zu erzählen warum
unser leben sinn macht und ob es so ist
oder nicht das sei dahingestellt dass
nun andere beurteilen ob es gott gehör
nicht und warum es das böse gibt das
weiß gott oder es war geil und ich hoffe
inständig sind zwei verschiedene
instanzen aber dass es gut tut
gegen diesen ständigen gedanken schluss
diesen quatschen den aneinander
kommentator in unserem hirn ein
gegengift zu entwickeln das ist ja
uraltes menschheits wissen die
buddhisten sind da ganz weit vorne
gewesen mit diesen achtsamkeit ritual
mit mit dem wissen darüber dass das die
qualität unserer gedanken bis hinein in
unsere körperliche substanz wirkt und
haben im prinzip das praktiziert was was
heute auch die neurowissenschaften sagt
und marc aurel hat auch einen tollen
satz gesagt auf die dauer der zeit nimmt
die seele die farbe der gedanken an und
rituale spielen in allen
heilungsprozessen aber auch in natürlich
alle religionen aber dazu muss man
überhaupt nicht religiös sein also
großes vorbild von mir ist auch jon
kabat zinn der hat die 18 teils
meditation in die wissenschaftliche
medizin eigentlich schon bei uns in der
sendung mit einer kollegin barbara
bleisch schön und der sagt zum beispiel
solange du atmest ist mehr an dir gesund
als krank es ist ein großartiges so
lange du arzt das meer in der
gesundheits kranken gehören dem moment
wo ich mal drei atemzüge bewusst
wahrnehmen man merke ich wieder ich habe
einfluss auf das wie ich mich fühle ich
habe einfluss auf meine gedanken ich
kann die weiterziehen lassen ich musste
nicht alle ernst nehmen
ich kann
spüren was mir jetzt in diesem moment
gut tut sich dann überlegen wofür bin
ich gesegnet wofür bin ich dankbar und
das sind einfache techniken wo ich mich
wundere warum ist das nicht schulfach
wenn das so gut tut dass wir jedem
ausgebrannten menschen in den kliniken
später das für teuer geld nach schulen
denke ich mal wie viel schlauer wäre es
für uns als gesellschaft grundwissen um
diese mind body medizin um leib und
seele in den kindergärten schulen ganz
natürlich lerne zu singen lernen dazu
tanzen lerne streit zu schlichten lerne
mit dir liebevoll umzugehen
wir haben so viele strukturelle probleme
im gesundheitswesen mit depressionen mit
übergewicht die auch oft seelische
ursachen haben
wo es keine pille für gibt ja und wo wir
machtlos sind als ärzte und das einzige
was hilft ist prävention und das setzt
an eine schulung des geistes genauso
ernst zu nehmen wie fachwissen
es gibt einen deutsch koreanischen
philosophen die jungs schule haben der
meint die rituale haben abgenommen
in der zeit und zwar deswegen ganz
spannend weil sie sich nicht
beschleunigen lassen
ein prozessor kann man beschleunigen
aber eine prozession nicht so wurde
geschichten zum beispiel haben nicht
einfach schneller erzählen haben eine
eigene zeit sehen sie das ähnlich total
schönes beispiel ist das tier ital
ich war mal in so einem zen kloster und
da gibt es ein ritual wie man den grünen
tee zubereitet und sozusagen in meinem
westlichen hektischen denken sitzen
neben denkt mensch alter nur noch jetzt
man beutel tanja und bist du kapierst
der ganze sinn des rituals ist die zeit
zu denen ist die zeit wahrnehmung zu
entschleunigen und wenn man das jetzt
tatsächlich mit wasserkocher und beutel
rhein werde der ganze sinn kaputt aber
das ist erst mal da finde ich diese
these sehr interessant auch eine frage
wie viel zeit wir einem thema eine einem
vorgang überhaupt noch geben die
ununterbrochen ist diese digitale welt
ist ja eine ständige ablenkung welt also
ich habe jetzt gerade mein natel mein
handy das liegt oben aber sonst würde
ich immer in versuchung sein
zugucken habe ich eine neue sms habe ich
neue e mail muss sich irgendwie
reagieren und dadurch ist unser verstand
ständig im einsatz an einem stress modus
in einem reaktions modus und rituale wie
zum beispiel eben auch das digitale
entgiften nämlich das ding aus zu machen
es nicht mit ins schlafzimmer zu nehmen
ist tage war es eben oder auch stunden
war es einfach zu sagen nein ich bin das
aufschlagen
das wird immer wichtiger je gestresster
die menschen sind deswegen stimmt es
ritual ist sozusagen bewusstes zeit
verschwenden und deswegen müssen wir sie
pflegen
das macht aber glücklich und es gibt
aber wieder ein gefühl dafür das leben
jetzt in der gegenwart zu genießen und
das das ist eigentlich der größte effekt
den wir auf zeit erleben haben nämlich
so banal es klingt dem moment
wertzuschätzen und darf wieder kontrolle
zu haben nicht die ganze zeit abgelenkt
und fremdgesteuert lassen sie uns noch
ein bisschen jetzt über die über die
menge zeit und medizin sprechen erst mal
gucken ja noch genug knapp 40 minuten
der glaube an magie spiel wieder
jetzt schon normalerweise wäre schon
längst ist dann hat man immerhin die
laptops sind kann einfach mal eine pause
machen zb ein durchatmen
wir haben ewig zeit nicht ewig lange
genug durchhalten
so klar wie ein magier steht doch in der
esoterik und in der alternativmedizin
eine große ehre da gibt es irgendwie von
hand auflegen über pennt und bis
kinesiologie homöopathie akupunktur jede
menge placeboeffekt und ich möchte von
ihnen eigentlich erst mal wissen ob für
sie das alles humbug ist als
wissenschaftlicher sicht oder ob da was
dran ist zb homöopathie werden in berlin
bresserberg ein kind von der schaut
gefällt dann kommen fünf mütter
angerannt um eben annika c30 globuli
weil das beruhigt die mütter maßgeblich
ich denke manchmal was lernt das kind
eigentlich dabei lernt im ungünstigen
fall dass man bei jedem wehwehchen
irgendwas einwerfen muss und das ist
eigentlich eine konditionierung die ich
gar nicht unterstützen würde wenn ich
als kind hingefallen bin hat meine
mutter mich in den arm genommen gepustet
und dazu gesagt schau mal erklärt dass
aua fliegt durchs fenster das günstiger
ja und ich habe das auto fliegen sehen
auch durch geschlossene fenster und das
für mich ein beispiel wie man mit einem
ritual aber vor allen dingen auch mit
dem ritual der zuwendung natürlich sagen
heilung oder beruhigung und sicherheit
wieder vermitteln kann einem kind und
selbst wenn ich als erwachsener an das
pusten nicht mehr glauben mag wäre es
dem kind gegenüber eine unterlassene
hilfeleistung aus klugscheißer rhein
nicht zu pusten
das heißt kann diese diskussion und sage
nationalistisch evidenzbasiert führen
dann ist völlig klar
diese globuli haben keine aktiven
wirksubstanzen wenn man sie gegen 14 uhr
testet ist da nichts dran keinerlei weg
so gesagt da gibt's 1000 studium
erwürgen wir müssen das nicht weiter
untersuchen das ist längst klar dass ein
schluck wasser
ja aber die kraft des rituals und vor
allen dingen die kraft des gespräch ist
das ist ja sagen
der wert der der geschaffen wird und ich
habe selber auch für mein buch
recherchiert ich wollte wissen wie fühlt
sich das an ich war bei einem sehr guten
hunger partner dieses gespräch war toll
ja das hat mir gut getan hat mir fragen
gestellt wo ich ins grübeln kam wie gehe
ich mit mir um
so las ich dampf ab wo
was mich und so weiter und so fort das
ist im kern ist es eine form von einer
kleinen psychotherapie und die kugeln
sozusagen die für mich die erinnerung
daran dabei zu bleiben und eine der
verrücktesten studien die ich kenne in
den bereich von dem harvard professor
tkatschuk er hat menschen mit
bauchschmerzen placebo gegeben und ihnen
dazu gesagt es handelt sich um placebos
er hat sie gar nicht getäuscht hat nicht
gesagt dass es hochwirksame bürger hat
gesagt nimm es trotzdem man wissen dass
das hier die hälfte er sollte sagt das
hat mir gut getan
das heißt dieses ritual ich denke das
wird mir gut tun und ich nehme mir zeit
für mich und ich konzentriere mich
darauf was ich will
das ist super und deswegen sollten erst
eben auch bei einem blutdruckmedikamente
den patienten erklären wofür sie das
nehmen was in ihrem körper damit
passiert und wie man das nimmt nämlich
auch nicht irgendwie nebenbei und zacken
und ich muss jetzt los sondern stellen
sich davor ein spiegel nehmen es in ruhe
sagen sie gottseidank lediglich im 21
jahrhundert wo wir dinge verhindern
können wie früher millionen menschen
umgebracht haben ich bin froh dass das
rechtzeitig erkannt wurde dass ich
meinen blutdruck senken kann
das wird mir gut tun zack haben sie eine
ganz andere haltung und eine höhere
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die leute auch
die dinge die ihnen nutzen einnehmen und
die ärztin soll sie dann nicht zu viel
erzählen über die risiken und neben dass
das wir machen genau das falsche mit
denen es gibt ja gut wirksame
medikamente bei vielen volkskrankheiten
ja die werden aber zur hälfte nicht
genommen warum weil die leute dann eben
bei praxl junger gott das ist ja total
giftig häufig wissen was häufig auf dem
beipackzettel heißt ne ich liege ja sehr
gut ein system prozent würden sie sagen
beim fußballer wenn er zehn elfmeter hat
und einen hat er getroffen
er hat häufig getroffen kein mensch
würde so reden ja das heißt die sprache
im beipackzettel ist völlig entfernt von
von von der wirklichkeit oder unseren
allgemeinen verständnis von diesen
worten und das ist eine nur cebu
kondition also 1 1 angst machen und hat
maßgeblich für die juristen in den
pharma konzernen eine rolle aber nicht
für den patienten
jetzt kam diese begriffe placebo und
nutzen was das genau ist schauen wir uns
ganz kurzen in einem werk spieler die
probanden erhalten am ersten tag
schmerzstillendes morphium
doch der arzt sagt es sei nur eine
salzlösung die patienten haben also
keine erwartung da morphium aber
tatsächlich ein hochpotente
schmerzmittel ist wirkt es trotzdem
entsprechend seiner pharmazeutischen
wirkung
am zweiten tag erhalten die probanden
wie der morphium
doch jetzt sagt es der arzt auch das
wissen und die wirkung des morphiums
führt zu einer positiven erwartung und
plötzlich wirkt das morphium doppelt so
stark dass ist der placeboeffekt am
dritten tag sagt der arzt er habe die
infusion gestoppt was zu einer negativen
erwartungen führt in tat und wahrheit
aber läuft die infusion weiter die worte
des arztes allein führen also dazu dass
die wirkung des morphiums komplett
ausbleibt
das ist er
ocb effekt toll erklärt ja es ist
irgendwie faszinierend also wie geist
und körper zusammenhängend freue ich
mich dass philosophen alleine eine
erwartung eine positive oder negative
erwartungen hat schon folgen
was passiert in unserem körper im gehirn
was das sich bei dem beitrag so gut
finde ist dass es rauskommt aus dieser
täuschung ecke also man denkt immer
bleibt placebo geht es um
scheinmedikamente nein wie wir eben
gelernt haben es geht um reale
medikamente die eine biochemische
wirkung haben und die erwartung oder die
negative erwartungen kommt noch und ob
oder wird davon abgezogen und deswegen
diese die die wirkung auf unser gehirn
diese diese trennung zwischen gedanken
und und neuro netzwerken übertragen ist
ja sowieso hinfällig ja also wie wir
wir haben da überträger wir haben
hormone wir haben angst wir haben das
belohnungssystem sozusagen die die
positiven gefühle schlagen sich in einer
andern hirnchemie wieder wasser
ursächlich ist oder was nicht aber ins
nutzen darüber ob es ein geist
unabhängig von der materie gibt glauben
sie ich wünsche es mir
ich bin bereit ist auch nicht so nicht
gibt von berthold russell den großen
skeptiker den den tollen zuspruch vor
gefragt wird sie der immer atheist war
kommen nach ihrem tod im himmel und
begegne gott was würden sie ihm sagen
und sagt du hättest mehr beweisen können
aber solange wir auf erden sind und
unseren geist so straff
sträflich vernachlässigen was die
chancen sind da drin bin ich sehr dafür
sagen die die diese positive erwartung
effekte zu nutzen ich mach mal ein
beispiel aus dem mittelalter da hatte
man überhaupt keine medikamente was
haben die leute gemacht die haben einen
satz aus der bibel aufgeschrieben wir
sind zettel gekaut und runtergeschluckt
um sich diese kraft der worte
einzuverleiben
und manchmal denke ich was wird
passieren wenn die leute nicht die
tablette schlucken sollen den
beipackzettel es war ein interessantes
experiment oder nicht so gut in ihrem
schönen buch neuen buch wunder wirken
wunder haben sie schalten sie zehn dinge
auf die wir über placebos wahrscheinlich
nicht wissen
und ich finde vor allem zwei sehr
spannend erstens placebos wirken auch
wenn man weiß dass das welche sind das
haben sie schon gehört
das wird nicht interessieren was ich
noch spannender finde ist den satz nur
etwa 20 prozent also ein fünftel der
konventionellen medizin sind
nachgewiesenermaßen wirksamer als
placebos ja und das ist ein hammer aus
sage und schreibe dann auch über meine
eigene knie operation wo ich im
nachhinein auf eine studie gestoßen wenn
die allen von uns zu denken geben sollte
da wurde nämlich patienten die für eine
knie- operationen an standen auch wie
bei einem medikament was man gegen
placebo getestet wurden die gegen eine
schein operationen getestet und man hat
dann den die knie op vorgegaukelt man
hat einen hautschnitt gemacht nachher
wieder zugenäht am knie um geruckelt und
das war natürlich hinter dem tuch und
man sah parallel sozusagen videos
angeblich live bilder aber natürlich
einen stabilen dachten das sei das
eigene kleine das eigene werk in der
krise so gut von innen das anders
ausfällt also 100 prozent der leute
waren überzeugt sie sind operiert die
hälfte war es überhaupt nicht und das
erschütternde ist es gibt im langzeit
ergebnis keinen unterschied zwischen
diesen gruppen dh die erwartungen zu
wecken denn ich wurde operiert eine
magische handlung wurde durchgeführt ist
in diesem falle genauso gut natürlich
akuter blind haben ist was anderes und
es gibt natürlich beim trümmerbruch auch
klare evidenz dass eine operation besser
ist als nichtstun
aber man muss konstatieren dass ein
guter teil von dem was wir heute auch
immer noch als akademische medizin
jeden tag in den kliniken für
unglaublich viel geld machen nicht
besser als placebo und das ist deswegen
habe ich bei wunder wirken wunder auch
immer wieder die perspektive gewechselt
weil ich sagte ich will nicht sagen dass
es weder auf die schulmedizin
eindreschen noch auf die alternative
erklären wo das gedanken geschichtlich
her kommt nämlich zum beispiel aus der
romantik auf dieser wunsch nach ritualen
da gibt es diese sauber mittel da gibt
es die blaue blume da gibt es das
homöopathische mittel was nur für mich
ist also da steckt unheimlich viel
romantischer geist auch drin philosophie
technisch und deswegen ist dieser streit
sozusagen um den richtigen weg ja auch
uralt er ist nicht erst in den 70er
jahren entstanden das über 250 jahre alt
von hahnemann pipapo von ihm gegründete
homöopathie und einen teil der dessen
was wir sozusagen immer als
wissenschaftliche medizin betrachten ich
wollte nicht wissenschaftlich und das
ist den nächsten leuten klar und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass das mein
buch hilft den menschen orientierung zu
geben und sich auch vor einer
überversorgung von unsinniger medizin zu
schützen
ich empfehle man fünf fragen vor einem
größeren eingriff damit man sich
klarmacht brauche ich das überhaupt
erste frage wo ist der nutzen manchmal
muss man dazu erklären der nutzen für
mich als patient nicht für die klinik
die das abrechnen
zweite frage ist wo ist der schaden wie
oft kommt nicht das raus was man will
wie oft gibt es infekte blutungen
nebenwirkungen dritte große frage wo ist
der beweis ist dass ihr hobby operieren
sie einfach gern herr professor oder ist
das die leitlinien der
fachgesellschaften riesenunterschied
frage nur vier was passiert wenn wir
abwarten und beobachten
selbst bei sowas wo man denkt da muss
man doch was tun wie prostatakrebs
werden eher klein ist wenn er nicht
schnell wächst lasst die männer in ruhe
dann sterben die an herzinfarkt und
schlaganfall das betrifft viel mehr
leute und die prostata ist bis zu ihrem
lebensende überhaupt kein problem
dann können wir aber noch sex haben und
auf die toilette gehen wann sie wollen
und haben eine viel höhere
lebensqualität das heißt wir müssen die
menschen inzwischen schützen vor allem
übergriff der medizin und der fünfte
sache ist gucken sie demgegenüber direkt
in die augen sagen sie würden sie das
was sie mir gerade empfehlen selber auch
machen in meiner situation und dann
kriegt man den arzt oder die ärztin
wieder zurück in das wofür heilkunde
eigentlich mal da war nämlich ein
empathisches
begleiten von patienten auf ihrem
lebensweg und das kann eben auch heißen
nicht zu behandeln
das kann auch eine gute entscheidung
sein aber wenn nur 20 prozent der
mediziner besser sind als placebos dann
sollte man doch 80 prozent abschaffen
und durch placebo setzen hätte man sehr
viel geld überreden für prävention für
kinder für alte menschen für medizin
sozusagen vor ort für
lebensstiländerungen weil das ist der
grösste hebel brauchen sie ich habe
nicht nein aber ich mache in meinem
neuen programm über eigentlichkeit den
leuten was klar nämlich wenn wenn wenn
wir immer denken subjektiv wir haben ja
unendlich viel zeit und mein körper
kriegt das alles hin sage ich immer
macht euch klar wie kostbar das leben
ist an summen zollstock ein kind was
heute geboren wird mädchen hat 50
prozent chance 100 jahre als werden hier
100 cm die männer sind nicht ganz so
august dauern
hier haben wir so ungefähr sich fühlen
sich sicher das heißt dass ihr werdet
werde ich erst eben wie alt sind sie
33 sie können das zuhause natürlich
gedanken mitmachen 33 dass wir hier so
und wenn sie es brauchen würden würden
sie mit diesem teil ihres lebens spielen
und gottseidank brauchen sie nicht aber
was ich den menschen die rauchen sage
nehmen sie sich das wirklich mal vor und
schreiben sie auf diese verbleibende
zeit alle dinge die ihnen wichtig sind
was möchte ich erleben wofür möchte ich
alt werden wofür möchte ich meinen
körper auch gesund halten dass man ein
positives ziel hat und nichtraucher in
sich ist ja auch kein positives ziel
nichtraucher klingt wie nicht schwimmer
das klingt so als hätte man es nicht bis
zum raucher geschafft also die sprache
ist ursprung unserer gedanken und man
braucht es visuell man brauche sinnlich
und dann ergeben sich daraus auch
konsequenzen für ihren lebensstil und
diese präventive medizin ist der zweite
teil nämlich wo ich sage wir können ganz
viele wunder in unserem alltag
vollbringen indem wir kleine dinge tun
bei namens beispiel ich habe mir immer
vorgenommen nicht mehr zu bewegen und
habe das immer nicht hingekriegt und
irgendwann habe ich meine
telefonrechnung gekriegt und ich sag wie
viele minuten ich telefoniere
dann wurde mir klar das ist ja
mobiltelefonen
ich kann mich dabei bewegen und ich geh
jetzt reden zweiten gespräch einfach
einmal um lack und automatisch habe ich
jeden tag mindestens 20 minuten
spazieren ja es sind kleinigkeiten die
aber langfristig den großen unterschied
machen
man sieht schon weil sie so sprechen sie
an ein großes anliegen sie wenn sich
auch eine breite bevölkerung sie
erreichen unglaublich viele menschen
sie machen im besten sinne infotainment
aufklärung humoristisch kabarettistisch
verpackt sehr einfach verständlich ihr
vater war pfarrer mein vater nicht mal
großvater ihm 12 trat er war der erste
der errichtung naturwissenschaft gegen
avatar der dessen vorfahren waren alle
faktoren
was treibt sie an eigentlich aber ich
habe schon so ein bisschen was von
diesen protestantischen ethos mit in die
wiege bekommen nämlich dass unsere
talente dafür da sind sie zum nutzen für
auch nicht nur für uns sondern auch für
andere
meine mutter hat mich auch natürlich
stark geprägt und auch die tatsache dass
meine familie geschichtet ist ich glaube
das ist auch das was wir in westeuropa
immer wieder uns in erinnerung rufen
dürfen
wie viele millionen menschen schon
erfolgreich integriert wurden und wie
wir immer schon wanderbewegung hat eine
freiwillige und unfreiwillige geflüchtet
geflüchtet die waren im baltikum in
waren deutsch balten in estland also
mütterlicher unterschiedliche sagte
haben sich erst hier in deutschland
betroffen sind
beim studium dann aber sie kamen 19 45
nach deutschland hatten alles verloren
und ich glaube auch meine beschäftigung
mit dem glück hat auch diese dieses
erlebnis was in der familienhistorie
kino gespielt
regner maßen mit integriert nämlich wenn
du alles materielle verlieren kannst und
plötzlich gut und weg ist und das
einzige was ist dein leben
was bleibt ihr dann bleiben wir zwei
dinge nämlich einmal was du an
fähigkeiten hast was du sagen dem kopf
trägt und was du im herzen trägt nicht
die freundschaften die sozialen
bindungen die familie und deswegen
glaube ich auch dass das dass mir das
immer ein anliegen war auch zu sagen
ein teil unserer kultur und unser
unserer hektischen raffgierigen
grundhaltung und alles ist ein
wettbewerb und du musst immer nummer
eins sein
das macht die menschen so krank und dass
das sich immer wieder daran zu erinnern
wie wenig wir eigentlich brauchen um
glücklich zu sein
das können wir deutschen noch schlechter
als die schweizer die schweizer sind in
umfragen immer zufriedener als die
deutschen also ich bin auch hier heute
um zu lernen
obwohl mir so viel besitzt ja aber die
schweizer haben sehr viel stärkeres
bewusstsein für demokratie für
selbstbestimmung für für kollektive
werte die haben also ein paar dinge die
die tatsächlich luxe technisch günstig
sind
worauf könnten denn sie verzichten im
reden also ich meine diese idee des
verzichts ist heute irgendwie sehr fremd
man mache das manchmal so temporär
digital die talks dass man nicht mehr
ersten auflage zum beispiel aber die
idee ist schon beiden historiker der
ganzen antiken wieder zufrieden epicor
ihren diese genügsamkeit minister sehr
wichtig worauf können sie konkret
verzichten oder hoch war würden sie
nicht verzichten wollen ich war
natürlich schon auf den weg zum studio
in versuchung in den nächsten
schokoladen laden zu gehen und mir die
genüsse der schweiz auch mit nach hause
zu nehmen
aber ich experimentiere gerade mit
intervall fasten das ist diese idee dass
man zum beispiel das abendbrot weglässt
und das frühstück nach hinten verschiebt
das zmorge und was dafür für den körper
günstig ist ist nämlich eine längere
pause zu haben wo man mal die
bauchspeicheldrüse die leber den damen
in ruhe lässt und einfach mal sieht
mensch ich kann 16 stunden ohne
nahrungsaufnahme gut unterwegs seien es
schadet mir überhaupt nicht und das ist
natürlich auch eine uralte spirituelle
technik nämlich zu lernen worauf gar
nicht verzichten was denke ich was
brauche ich was brauche ich in
wirklichkeit und das macht sehr
zufrieden und man nimmt dabei ab ich
habe schon zehn kilo so verloren wenn
wir das glück reden sie ein glücks pro
es gibt eine eine schöne geschichte des
technischen physikers news
finde ich unglaublich gut gibt es
verschiedene varianten die eine sagt er
hätte über seiner tür ein solches
hufeisen hingehängt und dann wurde er
gefragt als aufgeklärter
wissenschaftliche mensch warum glauben
sie daran
dann sagte er ich glaube nicht daran
aber man hat mir gesagt es wirkt auch
wenn auch wenn ich nicht daran glauben
das zeigt wie diese paradoxien diese
schwierigkeit einerseits dieses positive
denken dass uns ja wissenschaftlich wie
gezeigt wird hilft im alltag aber andere
zeit sie auch diese dieses diese skepsis
die wir erwachsenen haben die wir auf
geteerten menschen haben und vielleicht
können wir nicht mehr an diese dinge
glauben
ich finde das gute im liebesgeschichte
auch dass wir bewusst wechseln können
also dass wir überlegen an welchen
stellen und bei welchen
lebensentscheidung ist es unglaublich
wichtig eben nicht nur nach gefühl zu
entscheiden sondern nach nach evidenz
wissenschaftlicher lage nach statistik
obwohl das so und sexy klingt der ruf
der schweizer bestsellerautor nicht auch
canon hat ja darüber viel geschrieben so
zeigen sie denkfehler entstehen
und ich finde es wichtig dass das dass
wir sagen lernen am besten auch eben in
der schule oder ganz früh im leben
welche art des denkens gerade passt und
wichtig ist und sie haben einfach so ein
vater den sie umlegen können von
rational auf gefühlsmäßig i ratio ich
meine wirklich
weil das bauchgefühl ja bei ding wo man
sich gut auskennt tatsächlich ein guter
ratgeber sein kann also ein erfahrener
arzt der 20 jahre lang sich mit einem
krankheitsbild beschäftigt hat wer hat
diesen diagnostischen blick da kommt
jemand rein und er weiß zu sagen
innerhalb von sekunden was mit dem los
ist das ist ja nicht dass dieses
bauchgefühl geben würde ich auch
vertrauen weil das auf viel erfahrung
wissen es beruht wenn aber jemand sagt
ich nehme ein pendel in die hand und ich
pendelt aus welches medikament mir jetzt
gut tut das ist bullshit und da dafür
muss man schon unterscheiden können ich
meine dieses positive denken das
interessiert mich noch bleiben wir da
noch ein bisschen dran positives denken
ist ist ein schwieriger begriff weil da
sehr viel esoterischer mumpitz auch
unter dieser flagge läuft also der
bessere begriff ist positive psychologie
und die beste stelle in europa ist hier
in zürich interessanterweise der
willibald ruch ist der psychologe der
sich damit am besten auskennt und der
hat auch über humor zum beispiel viel
geforscht weil es eben in der positiven
psychologie um das geht was
resilienz fördert nämlich was uns
stärker macht also die psychoanalytische
tradition in einem satz wenn jemand eine
schraube locker hat liegt eine mutter
hat ja immer betonen was wir alle aus
schlechten erfahrungen lernen und die
positive psychologie hat gesagt mensch
warum gibt es so viele leute die auch
schreckliche dinge erlebt haben die aber
nicht daran zerbrechen sondern
vielleicht sogar auch sogar stärker
werden dadurch und das finde ich total
spannend aber es hat auch eine kehrseite
nämlich die hohen erwartungen die
positiven erwartungen und das ist ein
großes hindernis am glücklich sein ich
merke ich an mir selbst einfach zu hohe
erwartungen nicht nur an die welt
sondern auch an sich selbst und
irgendwie das oder den mittelweg zu
finden bin ich wirklich sehr schwierig
wer ich bin auch mit dem
wer im schnitt den lebenskunst
philosophen er war er schon der war
schon hier hat mir mal schönen satz in
meinem hinterkopf gepflanzt er sagt er
nicht 80 prozent der tage sind auch
alltag also sich nicht denn nicht so
denken heute muss der glücklichste tag
meines lebens sein
diese erwartungen ewig hoch zu schrauben
ist tatsächlich ein absolutes anti
rezept zum glücklichsein und glück ist
auch nichts was man direkt ansteuern
sollte sondern ist es eigentlich ein
nebeneffekt nämlich von einem erfüllten
leben was orientiert ist an an kohärenz
wie das in deren zusammenhang
gesundheitsforschung heißt nämlich meine
persönlichen werte meine ziele sind in
übereinstimmung mit dem was ich tue es
ist ich habe das gefühl ich habe
einfluss auf mein leben ich bin nicht
opfer ich bin gestalten der das sind
alles dinge die die auch wirklich
wissenschaftlich belegt sind und das ist
was ganz anders als ich bestelle im
universum alles was ich mir wünsche und
dann kommt das ist das ist unsinn
aber den menschen das gefühl zu geben
auf welche bereiche meines lebens kannst
du einfluss nehmen und über das das ist
ein übungs weg es ist auch nicht leicht
und das ist auch wirklich etwas was aber
auch beruhigende weise ist nämlich das
hufeisen dafür nehmen kann
die zufriedenheit im leben ist bei
vielen menschen eine kurve das heißt in
ihr mal dass ich sie wahrscheinlich
gerade hier ist aber es wird besser
es ist diese welt ist dieses jahr 50
stabil ist das nennt sich sozusagen
diese der tiefpunkt ist die rushhour des
lebens sie sind gerade bei karriere zu
machen sie haben eine junge familie
sie haben 1000 dinge an die an ihnen
zerren
und da ist man vorher freier und danach
auch wieder
es gibt einen schönen jüdischen witz
warten beginnt das leben protestant sagt
mit der einnistung der eizelle katholik
nein herr kollege und mit der
befruchtete eizelle und erachtens nach
das leben beginnt wenn die kinder aus
dem haus und der hund tot ist und daran
ist was dran nämlich das geht zu sagen
bergauf wenn wir das leben als
reifungsprozess begreifen
wenn wir gelassener werden denn jetzt
zufrieden er werden wenn wir nicht im
groll und den rock schauen sondern die
fülle des lebens mit auf und ab annehmen
dann lassen sie uns zum schluss noch ein
heißes messer durch das ist gut zum
schluss noch ein bisschen über den humor
und wie das lachen sprechen sehr gerne
sie haben sicher einen lieblingswitz
nach vielen ich mache mit meiner
stiftung humor hilft heilen gerade
mehrere studien welche rolle humor
tatsächlich auch wissenschaftlich hat
und auch unter anderem unterstützt uns
auch hier die universität zürich und das
soll ja so gesund macht ja mit mit jenny
hoffmann und dem willibald ruch und wir
haben bei pflegekräften zum beispiel
humor seminare beheben und belegen
können dass die beschäftigung damit was
wie gehe ich mit mir selber um wie gehe
ich in kontakt wie bringe ich meine
persönlichkeit ein
was mag ich eigentlich selber an humor
dass das eine positive auswirkung hat
auf den stresslevel auf die
zufriedenheit
auch auf den übrigen hat der patienten
und das ist etwas was in der medizin
lange nicht ernst genommen wurde
und so gesehen hat humor hilft heilen
meine stiftung ein ernstes anliegen
damit zu sagen
los ging es ja mal mit den clowns im
krankenhaus das macht die formation
theodora in der schweiz vorbildlich
deswegen in der schweiz keine projekte
aber in deutschland und dann geht es
immer über die workshops und die
wissenschaftliche begleitung davon und
wir machen ein projekt in der
palliativmedizin gerade wo wir zu
menschen gegen die lebensbedrohlich
erkrankt sind die wissen die haben nicht
mehr lange und da habe ich einen witz
erzählt ein mann der mir gegenüber lag
und wusste dass er nicht mehr lange hat
ein mann springt aus dem fallschirm raus
aus dem aus dem flugzeug und will mit
dem fallschirm zur erde segeln hat die
erste lange nichts passiert
mein gott sei dank habe ich den
rettungsschirm und zieht die zweite
lange und wieder passiert nix und
ungebremst rausch der nach unten in die
tief und denke das war es jetzt mein
letztes stündlein hat geschlagen
plötzlich sieht ja wie ein anderer mann
gefangen im erdboden entgegengekommen
luft fliegt ja
und er denkt wache ich träume was soll
das ist das vielleicht meine rettung der
ruf reparieren sie fallschirme und der
anruf nein aber gasleitungen und der
mandela hat sofort gelacht und kapiert
dass das mit der frisch natürlich dafür
steht dass wir alle uns im freien fall
befinden ja wir kommen aus staub wie
werden zu staub deswegen meinen die
meisten menschen ist muss im leben darum
gehen viel staub aufzuwirbeln und wir
können uns aber in diesen existenziellen
momenten begegnen wir können darüber
verzweifeln weil wir können darüber
lachen und dafür gibt es das lachen
damit wir nicht verzweifeln tränen die
man gemacht hat muss man nicht mehr
weinen und sie machen ja humor und und
witze haben eine erkenntnis funktion das
ganze an dem buch sie lernen also uns
dass wir umdenken und alte denkmuster
verlassen kreativ denken und so weiter
das ist das eine und das andere ist dass
es uns distanz bringt zur welt und auch
zu uns selbst und jemand der das
vorbildlich macht ist der dalai lama und
wir haben eine szene vorbereiten die
ziemlich lustig ist und schon gar kurz
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ja da kann man sehen wie man ja man hat
ja unglaublich viel leidvoller erfahrung
um sein land und man könnte auch sagen
wenn stil wird es immer noch nicht frei
und die die zerstörung der kultur geht
immer weiter und wieso lacht er darüber
ja er lacht ja nicht darüber sondern er
versucht sozusagen den spirit hoch zu
halten und das ist eine andere haltung
und das löst natürlich viele
missverständnisse aus aber es hat wie
wir eben auch gesehen haben natürlich
auch was anstecken ist und auch was
vorbildlich ist für die welt und ich
habe diese verbindung zwischen humor und
erkenntnis auch erst über die zeit
schätzen gelernt
humor hat ja schnell für viele leute
sowas ja das ist oberflächlich aber erst
mal zurück zur zum ernst der lage
und da sage ich nee das ist ein grund um
sozusagen humor so abzutun denn humor
ist eigentlich dafür da dass wir freude
haben am korrigieren unsere eigenen
annahmen über die welt also
philosophisch haben sich da auch schon
die griechen und kant und alle großen
schub mauer hat gesagt jedes lachen ist
eine kleine erkenntnisse also diese
geringschätzung des humors ist etwas
sehr deutsches ich weiß nicht wie es in
der schweiz ist ich finde wir haben
einen soliden humor ja aber individuelle
natürlich unterschiedlich aber jetzt
lernen
er hat mich als junge schon mit zauberei
beschäftigt und diese erkenntnis im witz
gibt es ja oft auch eben eine täuschung
der sinne und es ist ein stabiler stift
und wenn man den hinterlässt ist aus
also wer jetzt ausgucken jemand sagt
immer die hand des schneller als das
auge stimmt sonst hätte man keine blauen
augen aber gucken ob sie sehen
vielleicht nicht verschwindet 12 genau
hinschauen
3 mein gott
und wo ist er hinter dem ohr humor ist
ja der perspektivwechsel das heißt wenn
nicht in den gleichen trick so zeigen
würde 123 werden sie keine sekunde
getäuscht sie täuschen aber heißt der
ich täusche ihren geist weil in dem
moment wo zwei dinge also eine sache
zweimal hintereinander passiert das
denken wer ist jetzt habe ich kapiert
wie es läuft das dritte mal wird genau
das passieren
wir bauen also eine erwartung auf die
dann enttäuscht wird und da kann man
sauer sein oder man kann darüber lachen
und in dem moment wo ich kapiere wir
menschen lieben die täuschung mehr als
die enttäuschung aber der wahrheit
kommen wir näher durch die enttäuschung
durch das ende einer täuschung versteht
man auch dass zauberei witze und alles
was uns kurz schauen aber dein lachen
lässt ein weg zur erkenntnis und
erkenntnis kann spaß machen als ihre
enttäuschung hier an spaß macht
sie wollten mit dem noch einen schönen
trick vorfährt ihre gelder war ja auch
ein meister der zauberkunst und ein
pärchen er hat immer löffel verbogen und
hat da die natürlich immer in der hand
gehabt ich wollte zeigen dass man diesen
wechsel auch verbiegen kann ohne in der
hand zu haben
du bist ein unappetitliches ist das okay
der sendung am sonntagmorgen auch klar
wo mein gott wenn der tod kommt und sagt
ich muss ihn davon ab gegen versuche ich
bin auch einmal zu verblüffen und sagt
liberto das ist kein dafür ist die gal
kann man humor ja das ist die
beruhigende botschaft auch hier in
zürich untersucht in zürich verstärkt
modell humor kann man lernen indem man
sich gezielt mit humorvollen menschen
umgibt sich damit auseinandersetzt wie
reagiere ich selber muss ich mich immer
ärgern kann ich auch anders reagieren
und alleine sagen die wertschätzung
dafür in sein leben zu bringen kann man
auch mit seinem humor tagebuch 33 gute
dinge aufschreiben ich auf dem weg
hierher habe ich schon wieder fotos
gemacht mit meinem handy von von
geschäften
in zürich gibt es anlagen wurde
wäscherei schreibblöcken 342 ja- als
sonderangebot und ich dachte mensch das
ist genau der aus wo diese eine socke
die familie gehabt in der waschmaschine
immer verschwindet nur die wieder
auftaucht also man kann trainieren
sozusagen in der welt wie sie ist
humorvoll der dinge zu entdecken und das
ist in den büchern habe ich auch ganz
viel von diesen schnappschüssen ich
glaube das foto ist damit drin mit
eingebaut um den menschen zu sagen guckt
hin und lernt sozusagen diesem
perspektivwechsel und der umgang mit
kindern ist natürlich auch großartig ein
sechsjähriger hat in der studie von
humor teilen gesagt man kann nie wieder
etwas verlieren wenn man weiß wo
irgendwo ist es ist das nicht ein
kleider für die sucht ja die erwachsene
sagen wir mal wo ist das ja irgendwo und
er sagt man kann nie wieder etwas für
gehen wenn man weiß wo irgendwo ist
jetzt haben wir doch schon am ende der
zeit eine letzte frage am anfang haben
sie gesagt auch die philosophen platon
und aristoteles haben gesagt dieses sich
wundern das staunen damit beginnt alles
vorüber wundern sie sich am meisten in
der welt ja wie wir die grundlagen
unseres lebens aufs spiel setzen obwohl
wir so intelligenz begabt sind setzen
wir zurzeit die demokratie ins spiel wir
setzen mit dem völlig idiotischen
ressourcenverbrauch die zukunft des
planeten aufs spiel
wir setzen mit den atomwaffen unser
aller leben aufs spiel
daran da fällt mir auch noch nicht mal
ein witz sein
doch einer von willigis jäger im zen
meister gesagt treffen sich zwei
planeten erde und venus die venus sagt
zu erde mensch du siehst ja schlecht aus
so sagte er ich hab homo sapiens versagt
die venus geht vorbei aber wir müssen
den nutzen viele mögliche nachfolge
gespräch es gibt hoffnung
ja und ganz zum schluss noch ein kleines
geheimnis
auch ich kann ein bisschen zaubern
vielleicht können sie sind noch ganz
kurz verabschieden und dann machen wir
schluss ja und jetzt gleich folgt
sternstunde kunst mit einem film über
das schweizer comedy duo ohne rolf und
nach nächste woche steht ganz im zeichen
des humors alle infos über die kommende
woche finden sie online auf swr3 punkt
ch am nächsten sonntag zeigen wir hier
eine sondersendung von 10 bis 12 uhr zu
einem leider sehr ernsten thema dem
krieg in syrien ein paar tiefen einblick
in die geschichte des konflikts und die
humanitäre notlage vor ort das sollten
sie auf keinen fall verpassen
nun aber wünsche ich ihnen erst mal
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]